[Musique]
les ruines paix revienne l'horizon de
madagascar le lâcher de montgolfières
birman ronan trottier ali son goût des
voyages à celui de la photographie pour
son exposition globe trotter et l'a
sélectionné 70 clichés le meilleur de
son tour du monde
mon père était aussi un peu passionné de
photo ils m'ont transmis le
le goût de la photo et c'est surtout
ensuite le voyage qui m'a vraiment
envie de faire ça le photographe amateur
a tout appris sur le tas il aime
particulièrement capturer des instants
de vie et leurs émotions
je déteste demander aux gens pour les
prendre en photo la plupart du temps
c'est plutôt de l'instantané parce que
quand on demande généralement le le
petit cachet n'est plus là l'instant
n'est plus là mais l'idée c'est qu'en
fait sonder portrait c'est aussi leur
rend hommage aujourd'hui sont des
portraits de personnes chez qui on a
soit vécue soissons des personnes qu'on
a rencontré les photos sont très peu
retouché tout se joue avec les réglages
de l'appareil
un gros travail est mené sur les
couleurs une véritable déclaration
d'amour au diversité de cultures du
monde
la couleur c'est aussi représentatif des
cultures qu'on a rencontrés et en fait
on s'aperçoit que c'est une planète qui
a beaucoup de couleurs pour le coup et
des coudes des cultures qui sont
qui sont vraiment basé sur sur des
couleurs assez particulière l'inde à ses
couleurs
la birmanie à ses couleurs le père ou
encore autre chose à ses couleurs aussi
et pour le coup ça fait partie vraiment
intégrant dans la culture un premier
voyage avec cette exposition pour donner
envie de destinations plus lointaines à
ses visiteurs
[Musique]